[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about all for once a
master plan to break out of prison which
i believe is going to happen very soon
as of the making of this video in season
3 of the anime
all-4-one has just been arrested and
sent to Tartarus which is a
maximum-security prison that is
specifically designed to keep the most
dangerous villains incarcerated and far
away from the rest of society on top of
that in the manga
all-4-one is still in prison as of the
making of this video so this is not a
spoiler for you anime only Watchers it's
a theory video about what is going to
happen next in the manga so prison
Tartarus is isolated from civilization
on a remote island that is accessible
only by a single bridge and inside the
prison itself the villains are being
kept underground and they are constantly
restrained and monitored to ensure that
they cannot use their quirks because
this prison is specifically designed to
keep the most dangerous criminals in
we've still never seen anyone escape and
as I said even in the manga which is
well ahead of the anime all for one and
stain two villains who have been sent to
Tartarus are still there however I
believe that for many chapters now in
the manga we have been getting clearer
clues that all-4-one is preparing an
escape and I believe this massive Prison
Break is about to happen very soon so
this is what I'll be talking about in
this video
if you enjoy this type of a mature
content and you want to see more feel
free to leave a like and if you're new
to the channel don't forget to carolina
smash that notification bell shout out
to both North and South Carolina
now the first clue that we have dates
all the way back to before all-4-one was
even arrested and specifically to the
forest training camp arc a major event
occurs during this arc that is often
overlooked because of all the other
things that are happening at the same
time in the event that I'm talking about
in particular is wild wild pussycat
member ragdoll being kid
and her quark being stolen by all-4-one
we know that all-4-one doesn't just
steal any quark he is only interested in
stealing quirks that will be directly
useful to him so for example even though
best genus tis one of the top-ranked
heroes all for one does not want to take
his quark because all for one feels that
this quark depends too much on the
user's own skill and it isn't compatible
with shigaraki z' personality and we
know that all for one is actively
looking for a new quark that would be a
good fit for shigaraki
so what exactly was ragdoll squirt and
why did all four one find it so
appealing the name of her quark is
search and it allows its user to monitor
and keep an eye on up to 100 people at a
time and this includes knowing their
location and their weak points
now the quark might have some other
rules and restrictions that we don't
know about since we don't have many
specifics about it but assuming that
this quark can really monitor the
location and weaknesses of 100 people
even if it's only within a certain area
and not anywhere in the world this is
still an amazing quirk for all for one
to have why because how much easier is
it to orchestrate an escape from prison
if you can monitor up to 100 guards and
know exactly what they are doing at any
given time not to mention also knowing
their weak points at any given time now
it's true that all for one obtained this
quirk before he was arrested but even if
he didn't obtain it for the exact
purpose of escaping Tartarus this work
will still be incredibly useful in that
regard and let's say that inside the
prison the guards can somehow stop
all-4-one from activating this quirk for
all we know he could have already passed
it on to an accomplice who will use it
to break him out but the importance of
ragdolls former quark is only one clue
that all-4-one is planning an elaborate
escape there are many more by the way
from this point on in the video there
will be spoilers from the manga
regarding other clues that we have
gotten so far about all four ones master
plan so if you are not caught up you
have been warned there is just no way to
look at the other clues without going
into the manga in Chapter 162 of them
a prominent legal villains member
carrillo GD is suddenly tracked down by
Gran Torino and sue cow cheese somewhere
in the mountains the heroes and police
were able to find him thanks to some
very convenient eyewitness reports and
they managed to take down kudo giddy and
arrest him with relative ease
considering the nature of quirkiness
quirk warpgate which allows him to
literally create portals and transport
himself and others wherever he chooses
as long as he knows the exact
coordinates of the destination and
remember that last part for later as he
is being arrested kudo giddy says that
he was in the area looking for a
gigantic villain known as giganto
macchia who is known for having enormous
strength and kuru goethe claims that
this villain is one of all four ones
faithful servants so that in itself
tells us that all four one still has
faithful servants with great power
roaming around Japan but that's not all
it is safe to assume that because of the
nature of kuru Geary's quark he will
definitely end up in Tartarus because
that is probably the only prison
equipped to stop guru giddy from simply
using his quirk to teleport out of any
conventional prison now remember how
Kudo getti needs to know the exact
location of a place in order to open up
a portal there we can safely assume that
Tartarus is a top-secret facility so
kudo giddy and other villains would not
know where it is located which means
that the only way for kudo giri to
ascertain the location of the prison is
to allow himself to be arrested and
taken there once he is there kudo giddy
will surely be restrained in a way that
doesn't let him use his quirk at will
but this means that he will now be in
the same location as all-4-one who we
know has ragdolls quirk which allows him
to monitor up to 100 people including
their exact location and weak points
don't forget that during the hideout
raid arc we've already had a chance to
see all for one forcefully activating
Krueger's quirk
even when kudo GD was unable to do it
himself my theory is that kudo giri
being arrested and sent to Tartarus
prison is no coincidence this was not
just a lucky break for the
this is all part of all four ones
ultimate plan to escape from prison and
moving on to other clues what exactly do
we know about that mysterious gigantic
villain who is a faithful servant of all
for one we know that his name is gegen
to macchia and this word gegen Tamaki a'
is actually the name of a great war
between Giants and the Olympian gods in
Greek mythology the Giants in Greek
mythology are a race that hates the
Greek gods and wants to destroy them and
what other direct reference to Greek
mythology do we have in boku no hero the
name of the prison Tartarus is a
reference to a deep abyss in Greek
mythology that is used as a dungeon for
the wicked and as the prison for the
Titans the Titans also being a race of
giant mythical beings in Greek mythology
who shared the same parents as the giant
if we try to compare the pro heroes in
boku no hero to the Olympian gods as
they are the ones with all the power in
society and they have special super
powers or quirks that in some case
resemble the powers of Greek gods then
it makes perfect sense for them to call
the prison they created to keep those
who are challenging their power at bay
Tartarus
same as the abyss that the Olympian gods
used to imprison the Titans who have
challenged their power and if we take
this reference to Tartarus in Greek
mythology seriously then we can assume
that all for one's faithful servant
Keegan Toma Kia will play a role in the
prison escape
perhaps by attacking Tartarus and
creating a diversion that all for one
will use to overpower the guards and
then take advantage of Caraga disk work
to escape and furthermore the most
recent chapters of the manga give us
even more clues about all four ones
looming escaped in Chapter 184 we see
the wild wild Pussycats discussing how
all-4-one steals and stores the quirks
of others and in a brief scene from
Tartarus we see all for once a honestly
it's a bit of a problem I see a good
quirk and I immediately wanted for
myself it's a bad habit
there's many I want to return but a
quirk has to be used whenever possible
and sooner
rather than later as he says all of this
all for one has a knowing grin on his
face clearly implying that he is up to
something we have also seen reports
lately of new more evolved nomu
appearing and in Chapter 186 in
particular pro-hero Hawkes tells
endeavor about rumors of normal
sightings all over Japan even though
there had been no confirmed normal
activities since all-4-one has been in
prison however then suddenly a
mysterious normal attacks and devaron
Hawks on the street in the middle of the
day why if there had been no confirmed
normal activity while all-4-one has been
in prison do we see a no move so
brazenly attacking the top 2 Pro heroes
in the street in broad daylight it
cannot be a coincidence and I believe
that this attack is directly connected
to all four ones escape plan which will
involve ragdolls quark kudo Giri being
arrested giganto macchia and new normal
activity my guess is that all four one
will use gegen to macchia and the normal
to cause a massive diversion which will
allow him to take advantage of ragdolls
quirk to escape Tartarus prison using
Kuro Geary's warp gate either gegen to
machia and the Noma will attack the
prison and while the guards are busy
fighting them off all-4-one will make
his move or gig on Tamaki and the nomu
will cause so much chaos that the police
will decide to move all for one to
another location and all for one will
escape during that transport attempt the
question that we might ask ourselves at
this point is why if all for one is so
intelligent and such an expert planner
did he allow himself to be arrested in
the first place one option is that he
didn't want to be taken and he was
arrested because all might really got
the better of him but even so he had
still taken precautions ahead of time
including stealing ragdolls quark and
these precautions will allow him to
escape the other option is that all four
one four saw his arrest but he allowed
it to happen in order to force his
successor shigaraki to become more
independent as a villain at the end of
chapter 94 of the manga when we see all
four one being led into Tartarus prison
for the first time and we realize how
severe
injured he was prior to his fight with
all night and that he was even blind for
the past six years and yet still managed
to stand against all night all-4-one
tells us something important he says
that all might missed his chance to die
and leave his disciple Deku on his own
all-4-one says that the reason a master
exists is to eventually let the disciple
stand on his own and all might miss that
opportunity because he wanted to stay
close to Deku but by being arrested
all-4-one did exactly what he is
accusing all might of not doing he
forced his disciple shigaraki to stand
on his own and to channel the hatred and
regret and losing his master into
becoming a better villain and if we look
at what happens later in the manga and
the way she got Rakhi and the League of
villains got the better of Chi sake and
the eight precepts of death at the end
of that arc this definitely shows a
clear progression and development of
shigaraki into a much better villain
than he was at the beginning of the
story
so perhaps all-4-one knew that he would
be arrested and he was okay with it
because this would force his disciple to
become more independent but we know that
all-4-one still intends to find a new
work for shigaraki a quirk that would go
well with his personality and
potentially even combined with his
current quirk decay to create an
extremely powerful combo quirk so
knowing that all-4-one still has
unfinished business with shigaraki and
seeing how she Guara ki has been able to
significantly develop as a character
since all-4-one has been in prison now
seems like the perfect time for
all-4-one to make his escape on an
escape that he might have been planning
even before he was arrested let me know
what you guys think do you agree with me
that all-4-one is about to escape from
prison or do you think that all-4-one
has already played his part in the boku
no hero story also let me know what type
of new quirk you think would best suit
shigaraki and how this new quirk might
interact with his current quirk decay
feel free to give me your input in the
comments or on social media I always
love hearing from you if you enjoyed
this type of content and you want to see
more be sure to leave a like to let me
know and if you happen to be new to the
channel don't forget to subscribe and
carolina smash that notification
bell you can follow us on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar for all the
latest updates as always thank you all
so much for watching and until next time
SIA space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]